see this jersey here the one with the
name written in Sharpie those are
jerseys that were actually used in a
division one college football game four
Virginia Tech jerseys were stolen before
this 2007 ACC matchup at Georgia Tech an
incident known as Jersey gate the
jerseys belong to four of the best
players at the time so with little time
to spare they were forced to borrow old
white jerseys from Georgia Tech they
even had to write their last names on
the backs in Sharpie Virginia Tech flew
in replacement jerseys for two of them
but Sean Glennon and tarad Taylor had to
play the entire game in the old jerseys
ironically QB Sean Glennon almost
committed to Georgia Tech and happened
to play one of his best games against
them in their own jersey with Virginia
Tech beating Georgia Tech 27-3 there was
no evidence for the break-in but rumors
habit that those four missing jerseys
were later seen worn by Georgia Tech
students at a party that night